the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today is the human power lab and
we're gonna start with a lab safety tour
that Gwynn is gonna run this is Gwynn
Jones who's a D lab instructor he's
teaching D lab design with a couple of
their people this semester
and has a lot of shop experience and a
good person to have as a resource around
so he'll do the safety tour once you
have the safety tour then you guys are
free to use the lab after hours which is
a nice resource and then after that
we're gonna split up into teams try to
divide the class evenly and I think
we're at about 16 students so 5 or 6
students per team and each group is
going to do a different thing and then
we're gonna switch twice so that
everyone does everything so the three
options are machining with Gwynn in the
D lab lab which i think is 102 but that
might be a lie water-carrying which
we'll start up here with me and water
pumping which will be outside in the
driveway outside the D lab so make sure
you know where your coats are if you're
not wearing a sweater because it's a
little chilly out and then we'll rotate
and hopefully we'll get done a little
early today but not a ton early so we'll
see
there's five of you so one person is
gonna be the spotter because some of
these water carrying methods are rather
challenging because the tour that you're
gonna do four times five one is a
spotter to do all the attempts you're
gonna go down this hall down the stairs
outside cross the street and then come
back and so that's to experience flat
surface nice and easy stairs more or
less easy depending on the method and
then some rough terrain so that's the
plan and the methods are traditional
American style a method that's common
primarily for women all over the world
and I may need help to get this up yeah
I'm totally gonna need help to get this
up you just work to get it centered and
then hypothetically you can do this with
no hands I've yet to meet any deal ever
who can do that but you meet plenty of
people who can filming countries but go
try to get to one hand when you're doing
it and if you see people who have been
doing this their whole lives not only oh
that was really bad good thing we have
to not only can they do it with no hands
but they sort of your head has a point
in the middle so they'll start on one
side and then when they get tired
they'll just go like that and switch to
the other side and it works which I
don't know how you do that so that's two
methods
number three is called a temp line which
is used in many developing countries as
well often in the same places they do
head carries and so for this one goes on
your forehead and uses your neck and you
kind of play with it to get it
comfortable in your neck in areas where
this is really common and people are
carrying one to two times their body
weight he's
most of their foreheads have ridges
because it just digs in because you're
carrying from a pretty young age and
then the last method is a called the cue
drum you can see here which was invented
actually there's two different groups
that do it one is a cue drum one is the
hippo roller and the idea is to help
kids carry water very far distances so a
lot of people are carrying water many
miles or at least a mile every single
day they're usually kids and women doing
it and so we're not even going to come a
quick close to a mile and we're
generally carrying less water than they
are and we ate a much better breakfast
and got a much better rest and much
better health so it will be a little
annoying but not as annoying as it would
be if this is your life so it's a little
snapshot so come on around let's get
started
that actually is pretty good
let it go down step by step
we kind of want the point of this module
to be is for you to understand how much
power we can generate with your arms
versus legs and said this is a pump that
uses your legs and that's a pump that
uses your arms everyone here is gonna
use both pumps to try to fill the bucket
and see how much harder you can generate
this pump was a redesigned on a plastic
injection water pump that was done by
the foreground of a project by dr. andis
and he made the entire thing out of
cement it's a way workable for the
developer you can measure power by
pressure times volume metric flow so
we're measuring volumetric flow by how
quickly we can fill a 5-gallon bucket
with water and the way we're measuring
pressure is reading is the hydrostatic
pressure equation which is Rho gh and so
we're gonna measure the height that
we're pumping the water to and then just
multiplied by the density of water and
gravity okay ready
okay 2:45 what happens is when water
pushes down on water goes got to push
down this way it pushes the marble
against that inner lip and creates a
seal and then on the top you have a PVC
pipe that has either a nail through it
or is bent to close it in some way so
that when water gets pushed this way it
pushes against the slip and then water
can flow around the marble and so it
creates a one-way valve it's actually
really good one-way valve and the cool
thing about it is it gets better with
time
because the plastic bends around to the
shape of the marble instead of other
one-way valves which get much worse
those time
you